okay I'm going to talk to you about cell
structure so cells make up all living
things
some organisms like bacteria just made
of one cell whereas animals and plants
are multicellular made of many many
cells so they're tiny kind of building
blocks of all living things and so what
we're going to start with is we're going
to start by looking at a plant cell so
around the outside of a plant cell we
have what's called a cell wall think of
a wall going around the outside of a
room so the cell wall provides structure
and support and right just underneath
the cell wall we have another structure
which is called the cell membrane what
the cell membrane does is it helps to
control what comes in and out of the
cell so it's a little bit like a bouncer
allowing only certain things in that's
going to be good for the cell and
certain things out so that's the cell
membrane what we also have is this part
here which is the nucleus the nucleus is
where all of the DNA is stored so where
all of the genetic material is stored
next up we have these things quite a few
of them in a cell particularly if it's
in a leaf which are called chloroplasts
now these chloroplasts is where we have
the site of photosynthesis now what
photosynthesis is is using light to make
glucose whenever you see the word photo
we note something to do with light
synthesis means making so in the
chloroplasts we have this particular
pigment called chlorophyll
and this is where those reactions happen
to allow the the plant cell to make its
own glucose now next up we have this big
structure in the middle of plant cells
called a vacuole
now this vacuole contains cell sap now
because it contains SAP it allows the
plant cell to have its particular shape
it allows the cell to remain turgid so
it's a weak solution of sugar and salt
contained within the middle the vacuole
next up we have these structures called
mitochondria difficult word to spell
just write it down for you now so my toe
conned RIA now in mitochondria is the
site of aerobic respiration robic
respiration is a way that we release
energy from glucose also using oxygen
the word aerobic means with oxygen so
all of these mitochondria throughout our
cell provides energy for the cell to do
all of its processes that it needs to do
so that there is a plant cell now how
does an animal cell compare I'm going to
draw it justice here so here is our
animal cell now the animal cell is
actually has fewer features in the plant
cell so just like the plant cell it has
a cell membrane also does exactly the
same job and that helps to control what
comes in and out of the cell it also
just like just like the plant cell it
also contains a nucleus so this nucleus
contains the DNA also just like the
plant cell it contains mitochondria
again exactly the same job the site of
aerobic respiration
now I've just realized I've forgotten
one feature from here which is also in
animal cells they both contain something
called the cytoplasm now what the
cytoplasm is is it's the jelly-like
substance with the jelly-like substance
within cells and when loads of chemical
reactions take place
so if jelly-like substance which all of
these other organelles are kind of
suspended within lo the chemical
reactions happen there so we can see
there's not actually anything that an
animal's animal cell has that a plant
cell doesn't have however there's a few
things that a plant cell has that an
animus animal cell doesn't have for
example a plant cell has a cell wall
chloroplasts and a vacuole all of these
three things animal cells do not have so
there's one more type of cell we just
need to look at so we are going to look
at bacterial cells now bacteria also
like plant cells contain contain a cell
wall they also contain a cell membrane
and they also contain cytoplasm so
there's some definite similarities right
there however instead of having a
nucleus remember both of the other two
had a nucleus where the DNA is stored it
actually got this long circular
chromosome which is called chromosomal
DNA now this is just where all of the
genetic information stored here and also
in these things called plasmids these
plasmids are just simple circles of DNA
notice how they doesn't have any
mitochondria
it also doesn't have a vacuole it also
doesn't have chloroplasts so the last
thing that we need to know about is this
strange structure that comes off a
bacterium called a flagellum now all
this for gel M is is like a little bit
like a tail it just spins around and
allows that bacteria to move because
remember a bacteria is a single-cell
organism so that's all thank you